[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to Google cloud
next 2017 coming to you live from San
Francisco I'm Dre Alfonzo a program
manager on our Google for education team
and host of the G suite show and I'm
Timothy Jordan a developer advocate and
host of the dev show we're incredibly
excited to be here today and have you
along for the ride
cloud next is the event that brings
together executives customers partners
engineers to help build the future of
the cloud and there are over 200
sessions of sessions on Google cloud
platform G suite Maps devices and more
many of which will be available on this
livestream channel over the next three
days or on Google clouds YouTube channel
later in the week and while you're tuned
in with us we'll be giving you a sneak
peek of what's going on at next and then
we'll hand you over to our keynote
speakers who will discuss Google cloud
offerings today and a vision for the
future we'll also hear about how our
clients and partners are embracing the
cloud and while Timothy and I are here
in San Francisco we have a huge global
community joining us live as well in
fact leading up to the event we asked a
few of them to say hi take a look
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
those are just a few of the many groups
tuning in to the live stream today in
fact there are more than 400 viewing
partners watching right now that's right
and people all over the world are
gathering for cloud next we have Dubai
Taipei Botswana and Warsaw just to name
a few pretty much on every continent we
got you covered
what a cool global experience by drea
totally totally ok so what's next so
let's see we've said hello they've said
hello what else we got well how about we
give everyone joining remotely an idea
of what it feels like to be on the
ground at Moscone Center in San
Francisco right now you know what I like
better you know let's check in with
someone here right now actually let's
see there's Dave Dave would you come
over here everyone good good having a
great time so far how are you all right
sits it's awesome this is it's crazy how
big this is
so for those of you on the live stream
that don't know Dave could you let other
who you are and what you work on oh sure
my name is Dave Ranson I I work on a
thing called customer reliability
engineering it's a group of Google sres
the people who keep our cloud up and
reliable actually going on call and
working with customers to keep their
applications up and reliable it's kind
of a new thing in the industry which is
interesting because reliability has got
to be so key to cloud yeah you know are
the basic religion is that reliability
is the most important feature of a cloud
because you know who cares about the
rest of it if you can't count on it what
are some of the most exciting or
interesting problems that your team has
encountered um you know I think I'll
tell you the thing that is been the most
awesome and surprising in a good way is
I thought when we started this we'd get
a lot of resistance you know
particularly for larger companies about
wanting to make the sort of changes you
have to make to get that kind of
reliability
turns out they're really hungry
and so it's been actually keeping up a
demand awesome well one last question
before we get going and what are you
most excited about for the future of the
cloud and what's happening at next well
I'll tell you the sessions I'm most
excited about here at next are two of
them 12:30 we have a necessary war
stories and then tomorrow a roundtable
the founding fathers of sre that's going
to be awesome
someday thanks so much for joining us
all right thanks Dave have a great one
all right so great chatting with Dave
and there's so many cool things going on
today so many people coming together in
collaboration around Google clash yeah
you know what I had a chance earlier to
meet up with some of our session
speakers and chat with them about cool
engineering topics that will be covered
today one of those things was about the
Internet of Things I love the Internet
of Things so let's get to that but when
we get back we'll find let's say a cool
demo plan yes all right hey everyone I'm
here with Indra Neil who'll be leading a
few sessions on IOT at next so he came
by the studios to give us a little sneak
peek on what we can expect
so intra know thanks for joining us here
today as mentioned you'll be doing quite
a few sessions on IOT at NEX can you
talk to us a little bit more about what
those are sure we have we have two
sessions in IOT at NEX
two breakout sessions one is called
developing IOT solution on Google cloud
and second is IOT and cloud for
industrial applications got it and
before we dive into that what do you do
at Google so I'm a product manager with
Google cloud and my job really is to do
anything everything yeah to build great
products which delights customer so I
work with customers to understand the
needs I work with our engineering team
very closely UX design team partnership
team so we're building features which
customers can really value and for we're
talking about IOT it next what why is
that important why is that important to
bring those types of sessions to folks
yeah you know I think IOT is that as an
inflection point we're seeing lot of our
customers across manufacturing retail
even logistics building really
interesting solution on Google cloud so
so you know I think we think like we
really want to serve
share with the broader audience what we
think internally how we think about IOT
internally and also sort of share the
products we have on cloud as well as on
the device side so that which developers
can use to build really scalable
applications and you mentioned an
interesting solution with IOT can you
talk can you give us a sneak peak in
terms of what are some of those
interesting solutions that you're seeing
manufacturing companies develop yeah so
in fact one in one of the session one of
our customer is going to sort of explain
I get deeper into a very interesting
solution they are built with
manufacturing clients where you know you
can look across all the different
factories and the manufacturing
processes remotely monitor it get
real-time insights across all your
factories so we think there's a lot of
value there awesome and so when we're
talking about the future of IOT what are
you most excited about yeah I'm really
excited about the intersection of piety
and machine learning if you think about
what we have done with our own data
centers we have collected vast amount of
data from chillers you know coolers and
our HVAC system in outside temperature
the humidity and wind speed and we've
cut it all this data and we have built
machine learning models which is
effectively improved significantly
improved our power utilization
efficiency so I think there will be a
lot more applications at this
intersection and that's really
interesting over next couple of years
awesome well thanks to general for
joining us today and definitely looking
forward to checking out the session
online
great thank you think okay we're here
now with Terry Terry could you tell the
livestream audience who you are what you
do hi my name is Terry Ryan I'm a
developer advocate for Google cloud
platform and my job is to basically go
around and talk to people about Google
cloud and try to encourage developers to
be successful on our platform cool so
we're here in front of a wall of pie but
most importantly we're in front of the
compute I crunch er tell us what what's
going on in front of us here so one of
the key things about Google clouds VM is
that he can pick very discrete amounts
of processor memory so you're not few
needs you know you don't have to choose
between 8 and 16 if what you need is 14
processors so this allows you to spin up
than VM to as many processors as much
memory as you want and we're gonna have
it to a job which is compute digits of
pi and so we can run this whole process
and you go from having no VM and having
a VM that's actually done work
calculating PI hundred million digits
and usually around a minute and do the
whole thing from nothing 200 million
digits a pie so I think that's just
incredible that Google Cloud is
computing a hundred million digits of pi
and you're spinning everything up with
just this one button here that's pretty
cool our our web UI may be a little bit
more clicked but we could get it down to
just this one one button to do that
actually that's my favorite thing about
the Google cloud platform is how easily
can scale with your business yep that is
I think one of the key differentiators
and the fact that you can make sure you
get is exactly as many resources as you
need without having to go over you save
money that's good too okay so in
addition to the PI cruncher what are
some other exciting things that we
should make sure that we're checking out
here at the Showcase well I'm a big fan
of the Wacka pod machine so whack-a-mole
but you're killing servers instead of
instead of moles we also have some great
things in in machine learning the
robotic candy sorter and dispenser is
one of my favorites teri thank you so
much for joining us thanks for having me
hi so we'd like to talk to a couple more
folks we know them as Mark and franceska
you know them as the hosts of the Google
Cloud podcast here we are with mark and
Fran Cesc of the GCP podcast how y'all
doing doing great
so a very simple and straightforward
question what is the podcast why don't
you go sure
so the podcast is a weekly audio content
that franceska and I put together once a
week and we do interviews with program
managers engineers customers a variety
of people across Google and outside of
Google to talk about how they use Google
cloud platform and sort of the lessons
they've learned and the cool stuff that
they can tell people about it
yeah sounds pretty much right in
addition to what you guys are doing with
the cloud podcast
do you guys do here so we are developer
advocates so basically I'd say that
developer advocate what they do is they
here comes they can I go around the
world talking about Google technology
and then if they hear good or bad
feedback they go back to the product but
product manager in themes and they give
the feedback back basically I've heard
professional sticker distributor
professional teachers two t-shirts yeah
can i still be at the party so I think
it's do a little bit more to I mean what
would you say is like your your motto
for developer advocacy so for me I would
say quite literally it is our job to
advocate for developers it was our job
inside Google to basically go out in the
world interact with the external
developers who use Google cloud platform
and then be able to be internally be
able to say hey like we represent the
interests and the experience of those
external developers to our internal
department managers especially in
engineering so that they have that sort
of conduit of communication to the
outside developers yeah
I'd say in three words like make
developers happy and I should assuming
that the podcast is a great way to reach
people but how did you guys come up with
the idea to do a Google cloud podcast so
so I think at Google for way longer than
mark and like Sears and I was not a
developer advocate before but I joined
developer advocacy and I've always liked
podcasts so I was thinking about doing
one and I was like this is way too much
we should do a podcast it was like
that's a good so far 61 today yeah yeah
yeah
61 so we passed one year of content a
little while ago so it's been pretty
response has been really really positive
from listeners and everyone
so it's been really great now y'all are
gonna be on the ground at necks doing
something really great for all the
viewers out there what is it yeah so the
idea is that we're gonna be in the
middle of club necks asking questions to
speakers and attendees and basically
trying to give everyone a taste of what
cloud next is and then really think that
as a bunch of how many of them but you
should be interesting we did it last
year it was really successful I think
we're gonna get a repeat this year again
hopefully last year we have some content
of people rapping that we never released
me oh yeah do that again this year I
somebody fine juniors rapping for us we
you're talking like cloud platform
freestyle yeah yeah if we can get
content on that level again I feel like
that's gonna be great for everyone
outside of next and unfortunately
couldnt be able to attend to be able to
get really a good taste of what happens
so for the folks that are gonna be
tuning in to the live stream to see
cloud next how do they get in touch or
get the the sessions you guys would be
hosting they're gonna be on you're on
the podcast so the sessions were gonna
be hosting during the event they will be
all recorded so that's cool you can
watch it later on and for our podcast it
will be available whenever we have TV
podcast in addition to being advocates
and getting out there and talking to
folks do you guys also do like
developing on the side and your role at
Google or is it just more so you're
advocating about it we do development I
mean it's hard to be a developer
advocate without being a developer
that's like there's people that do it
right but like the empathy I was like oh
I feel good pain that is very important
so yeah we were a lot of code
mostly for fun yeah yeah like demos and
like what did you do like a puddle
sucker yeah my my thing is like like a
paddle sucker multiplayer game I made
happy angry surprised which was
rock-paper-scissors but with people's
facial emotions yeah that was fun yeah
we do a lot of silly stuff with
thousands of servers in the cloud that's
excellent really high let's go yeah but
it's okay as long as it can be you know
played by millions of people at once
it's fine
okay one more very person coolest
engineering moment in all of history
go so I think when the Mars were ever
landed like the stuff that they had to
do I have no idea how to get like the
jet propulsion to happen in Reverse so
that they could land properly and they
actually managed to do it to make the
Curiosity rover land like I watched that
whole thing with just absolute
fascination I was I was completely
enthralled I'm gonna go with the first
phone call because they think that
actually change the world yeah like the
first time that someone got a phone it
was a hello and someone on the other
side said hello mmm that's pretty
amazing all right before we get going I
give us all the addresses where to give
the podcast where to get in touch with
y'all we do these all the time on the
buckets we do
GCB podcast com we have an email hello
at GCP podcast comm we're on twitter at
GCP podcast Google+ plus GCV podcast and
also on reddit slash are slash DCP
podcast and finally on slack slack you
can find us on the hash podcast channel
dolly / g CP - slack yeah thank you
thank you I love hanging out with those
guys the best part was hearing about
their favorite engineering moma small
history okay so we're just a few minutes
away from the keynote I think so
maybe it's time to let everybody know
what to expect perhaps a sneak peek of
what will be covered you know I think
it's about that time so for the keynote
today we'll be hearing from Diane Greene
SVP of Google cloud on a recap of 2016
and what's next for Google in 2017 and
sundar pichai Google CEO on how we're
bringing all of Google to enterprise
customers and then Diane is gonna be
back to explore how our customers are
using Google cloud products across their
companies to innovate everywhere from
security to analytics to machine
learning
we'll hear testimonials from several
Google cloud customers who will be on
the stage with Diane
oh the next we'll do a deep dive into
machine learning for the enterprise with
faith daily chief scientist of cloud AI
in
learning and finally we're here some
closing remarks from Google's chairman
Eric Schmidt ok now I'm really getting
excited too and it looks like folks are
just starting to get seated well before
we hand you over to the big stage I'd
like to let you know the jury and I will
be back tomorrow before the keynote with
day one in review and more exclusive
interviews that you won't want to miss
we'd love to hear your thoughts on the
future of the cloud or answer any
questions for you while we're here with
all the experts you can find us on
Twitter our handles are on your screen
enjoy the show and we'll see you
tomorrow see ya
[Music]
[Music]